un mot là-dessus que c'est c'est ça
montre simplement la continuité
dans la conception qu'on entretient du
rôle de l'école de une sorte de
déculturation il y a
il y à un utilitarisme
généralisée qui s'est développée durant
tout le 20e siècle et qui a conduit les
responsables politiques et j'allais dire
peut-être même les élites dans le sens
le plus large du terme à
faire de l'école un objet utile
aujourd'hui l'école ne sert plus à
émanciper l'individu et à lui fournir
une culture dans le sens le plus noble
du terme et sert à avoir un job donc
forcément quand on fabrique de l'élève
qui est destiné à avoir un job on le met
en connexion avec les différents aspects
les plus utiles pour de la société marée
basse il va s'y ranger au cp ils font
quoi eh ben ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
dit que puisque demain il faudra
absolument être connecté bien des cp on
va commencer à réfléchir aux manières de
connecter l'enfant aux langues
étrangères aux cultures étrangères à
l'internet et donc finalement on
s'éloigne de ce qui a constitué pendant
des décennies le socle fondamental c'est
à dire je veux acquérir demain à savoir
il faut que je puisse aujourd'hui savoir
lire correctement pour aller le chercher
une autonomie parce que c'est ça
finalement que montre aussi l'étude
c'est qu'il ya une incapacité à
interpréter les données donc là la
réflexion des enfants de france est
vraiment en recul à côté de ça j'aurais
tendance à dire juste pour terminer
qu'il faut aussi qu'on prenne en compte
la nature multiculturelle aujourd'hui de
notre société qui forcément à mon avis
intervient d'une façon ou d'une autre
quand les parents ne parlent pas la
langue c'est beaucoup plus difficile
pour un enfant qui entrent au cp
d'apprendre à lire en cinq ans que pour
un enfant qui a quitté baigne au
quotidien dans l'enfance